My name is Kellsie Zapata,
and I am a team member at
Zapata's Cleaning Services.
Today, we'll be showing you
how we deep clean a kitchen,
especially the areas
that are commonly missed.
A lot of places that are missed
are places that are just not seen.
So, for example,
you don't see behind your refrigerator,
you don't see behind your oven,
you don't see where your hood filter goes.
It's something that's commonly missed.
And if items like these
are not cleaned properly,
they're not going to last very long
and you're going to get a lot of dirt,
debris, and buildup.
Most kitchens will have the filters.
They're always going
to be above the stove.
This was a outdoor hood vent filter.
So I think maybe it being outside
made it much more worse,
because of the weather.
So, once we have our gloves on,
we take all the pieces down carefully,
and then we spray it down
with our favorite degreaser,
which is Dawn Powerwash.
The worse the buildup,
the more I'll let it soak.
So these, we let it soak
for about a good 30 minutes.
We turned the hot water on,
let it run for a few seconds,
and then we rinsed it all off.
One of their jobs is to capture the grease
while you're cooking, and
that grease can build up
and turn into thick layers of grease.
And that's why you want
to clean them regularly,
at least once a month,
maybe even more if you cook a lot,
so that all that grease can get cut down
and the filter can continue
to do its job properly.
We had to get a scrub brush
to kind of get some of the pieces,
but for the most part,
the Dawn was able to lift all of that.
This is an older-looking one.
They all look differently,
but they all do the same job.
Their job is to circulate
the air and catch the grease,
which is why you see those brown marks.
That's all grease buildup.
So your filter should not look like that.
If it does look like that,
you need to clean it.
And it's important to remember
that not cleaning those hood filters
is also a smoke hazard,
because that steam and smoke
is going to stay in that filter.
Down here in Georgia,
we deal with a lot of hard water.
So a lot of that buildup,
besides the grease that you see,
a lot of those white marks
are just hard-water buildup.
We put our gloves on.
We did not want to
touch anything in there.
And we put our mask on
because the smell was very foul.
We pulled out all the filter pieces.
We did soak it in hot water and vinegar
to try to loosen as much
of that food debris off.
So, vinegar is acidic,
so it will eat away at things.
It's a really good natural cleaner.
It worked, but there was
still stuff caked on there.
We went in with the Dawn Powerwash,
let it sit for about 20 minutes,
and then it looked brand new afterwards.
Then we tackled the dishwasher.
I poured vinegar all on the bottom
of the dishwasher to mask the smell.
They were there for six months.
There was food, just
food, pieces of chicken
that were just stuck in the inside of it.
So there's no way that they
were rinsing the dishes.
Then, when I realized
how thick the grease was,
we had to bring out our Dupray steamer.
And once we brought our steamer out,
it made the cleaning so quick and easy.
The grease was lifting,
the hard-water marks were lifting.
The steamer will sanitize, degrease,
and disinfect, all with water.
So, once everything was
clean, to an extent,
we put all the filter pieces back,
we locked them into place,
we put the racks back in,
and then we got an
Affresh dishwashing tablet
and we put it where the
detergent pods go in,
and then we ran a normal, high-heat cycle.
So, with a normal dishwasher,
first thing we do is we
always take out the filter,
scrub it with some hot
water and some vinegar
to get any food debris off,
rinse it with water,
put it back into place,
and then I'll get some vinegar
and spray the harder-to-reach areas,
like where the sealant part is.
I'll spray that with the vinegar,
scrub it with a grout brush,
and I'll put everything back
and I'll use an Affresh tablet.
Or if I don't have those on me that day,
I will pour some vinegar
into a dishwasher-safe cup,
put it on the top rack, and
run a hot, normal cycle.
The vinegar will lift any soap scum,
grime, or any other sticky residue.
So, after your vinegar
cycle, pull out the rack,
take out that cup of vinegar,
and then we'll pour baking soda
on the bottom of the dishwasher,
close it back up, and run
another hot, normal cycle.
And the baking soda will
really help deodorize
and take out any weird smells in there.
It's important to use these
two products separately.
You don't want to use them together,
'cause if you use them together,
they turn into salt.
You want to clean this appliance
at least once a month.
This is because a dirty filter
is not going to get your dishes clean.
You're going to come across lots of dust
and just whatever has
slid under your fridge.
And also, if you have pets,
there's going to be a lot
of pet hair back there, too.
After we safely move the refrigerator,
you don't want to yank it,
you don't want to pull it
because it is going to
be connected with a wire.
Just kind of check the area
and make sure there's no loose wires
before you just start vacuuming.
And we start vacuuming the baseboard,
the wall, the coils
to get all that dirt and dust off.
We used a foaming action spray.
We used a microfiber cloth,
because that's really good
at trapping dust and dirt.
You want to at least pull that out
two to three times a year.
If you have a bigger family
and you have a lot of pets,
you probably want to do it more,
but at least a minimum
of three times a year.
Cleaning the inside of a oven
is probably the last thing you want to do
after cleaning your whole kitchen.
So the more you let the oven go,
the worse it's going to get.
So that's just cooking
oils and food splatter.
So, first thing we do
is pull out the racks,
and we will spray the racks down
with the blue Easy-Off.
And the reason that we use
the blue can of Easy-Off
is because that is an oven cleaner
that is safe for self-cleaning ovens.
Once we spray the racks,
we then go back to the oven,
and we will check out
the bottom of the oven.
And if there's any loose
or burned food debris,
we will wipe all that
out with paper towels,
try to get as much of
that loose food debris
off the bottom of the oven,
and then we go in with the Easy-Off
and just spray a generous
amount of product.
And then we close the door and let it sit
a minimum of one hour and 15 minutes
depending on how bad the buildup is.
We go in with SOS pads and
scrub and scrub and scrub
until everything comes off.
They are a type of steel
wool abrasive pads,
and they are the thickest
grit that you can use.
We'll wipe that first layer of
product off with paper towels
to get as much of it off as possible.
And then the key is to rinse with water.
So we'll spray water, we'll
wipe, we'll wipe again,
and we'll wipe again.
Because one common question
we get with this product
is, "I've used it, but it
leaves a white residue."
Well, that's because you didn't rinse.
You're going to want to rinse your oven
at least four or five times
to ensure that all that
product is taken off
and nothing stays behind.
About once a month,
give it a deep cleaning.
We do not encourage the
self-clean oven cycle.
There is way too many risk
and fire hazards with that.
You know, when you cook on your stove top,
grease and food's going to splatter,
and it can fall on the sides of the oven.
In this particular instance,
we used a Scour Daddy,
which, a Scour Daddy is really good
at lifting thick grease, caked-on grease.
We used the Sprayway cleaner too
because it has that foaming action
that can really lift all that buildup.
And then we just kind of went back over it
to make sure everything was taken off.
Bugs will definitely get drawn in there,
especially if there's food
that gets stuck in there.
So when you pull it out,
you might see some dead
bugs stuck in there.
And if you're ever wondering
if there's a foul odor in your kitchen,
pull out your oven.
There might be some stuff
that's gotten behind the oven
and on the sides of the oven.